welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live our little
podcast loyaltygaming.net laura cognito
here with some amazing devs we got
russell chris what is this fine
gentleman in the room that we have today
i'm james from mega cat studios
i get cats do that this is the one they
showed on the nintendo direct i believe
and people were excited they saw the
wrestling fest they saw a lot of classic
wrestling vog for the people who don't
know about this game what is the premise
of us so wrestle quest is the world's
first wrestling rpg
we took everything we loved about
wrestling and to most of us those top
two or three memories
from being introduced to wrestling of
the child include action figures still
right of course of course so wrestler
quest is toy story meets wrestling so
you got kind of the articulated joints
and the general makeup of the world so
it's it's very much this imaginative
storytelling based universe so we have
awesome 30 iconic legendary wrestlers
licensed into the game nice and 100 of
our own characters you're saying some
legendary
brother
the head cam right here
he's just a legendary jump jump
no no no no no no
jeff's real old i'm his son
we got to play by the rules we have the
legend in the building so tell us real
quick your role in the game and uh your
excitement for the project you want
double j to terry or jeff wjdwj double j
created it i own it
i'll win it i'm kidding
i'm a producer in the game and uh i'm
actually in the game and a big fan of
the game most importantly awesome first
i'm paying close attention to that is
something built around storytelling
never have an rpg
it's crazy right right some of the best
story lines and and literally we have an
rpg out there so tell us what's going on
right now for people what's going on so
at the beginning of the promo here we're
learning the basic ropes so as any jrpg
we have tons of turn-based opportunities
for you to just dig in
based on your character archetype defend
attack taunt
certainly heat up that eventually
becomes double tag team a triple tag
team
so right now we have randy santos
muchacho man he's your primary
protagonist you know he starts off at
the very beginning of the game he's
inspired by 80s wrestling okay
so as he canvasses this this toy world
universe
he picks up new colleagues comrades some
faces some heels for 12 playable
characters
build that is stable and makes a ton of
unique decisions to save the world that
is awesome first of all the animation is
absolutely fantastic very over the top
love that art style like what made you
go with the art style
a big part of nostalgia for us was like
that that early 80s breakout of home
consoles arcades and nintendo right so
so we took that core kind of piece and
made it a little more high fidelity you
know modern game sensibilities modern
post-processing dynamic lighting systems
nice
but still giving it that that really
core personal nostalgic kind of overload
absolutely obviously i love what's going
on now we got the hype meter all right
we're going for the pin and we get that
one two three
are we getting it
if he had kicked out he would have
gained about 10 of his hit points back
okay that creates a little bit more of
an ebb and flow of like a race reward
based on when you pin them and how hard
you wait gotcha so now as far as like
the long-term aspects we're building up
we're leveling up now we're seeing we're
getting now we're getting to the
attribute aspect right and this is that
we got a speed like charisma i'm
assuming what are some of these
attributes here that we can uh we got
everything you'd expect in an rpg man
let's go let's talk about it
and you have a specific uh interest you
want to dig in
for example what is the like acc so we
have the action points right here
can actually see where exactly yeah
let's get zach good zack at the building
you guys know where zach is
well while they getting zach in the
building what you see there's a lot of
hardcore rpg mechanics and a lot of
attributes
yeah speed charisma power hp we got your
dog you got the attack i'm assuming
right cl
all right so now can we add can we add
here now could you're like okay there we
go and now now breakdown new gimmicks we
gain more gimmicks in the game so you
guys at the beginning of the tutorial it
actually goes through like the four
different move architects so one of them
is gimmick nice this is real cool so
remember to keep things excited all
right they're teaching them what's going
on now the other thing you also
mentioned before we started was almost
like voice acting and
getting some of those personalities
those classic personalities how did that
process go and it's i hear someone about
but
well my question is like what makes you
go the extra mile to try to get that
authenticity for the voices
you know you think about i guess the
question is
how do we apply voice acting in the game
yes that's the first
i guess in this case when you're
thinking about classic wrestling so much
of that like the vignettes and the
promos and the mic work right so very
much required to capture that essence i
have to imagine there's a certain
percentage of the audience that'll play
wrestle quest that are huge rpg fans
that don't know anything about wrestling
right so we're gonna give them the right
carpet treatment nice
and i think that's a cool a cool way to
look at it too because there's some
people who again they're familiar with
some of the imagery some of the
characters but they may not be wrestling
fans so this but an rpg can kind of get
there
this is actually the first smack talking
sequence right so he's getting his first
promo he's in the a b room that's his
mentor kind of training facility
teaching them what it's like to get the
mic going i love it i love it so which
one you picking at it not as stupid as
your face
you go the other way plus fine fighting
all right get the hype
okay blind fighters she's talking that
talk
okay
so again we have that choice mechanic
now are there anything that that would
influence probably like failing or not
doing as well with this election or
what's the question as far as these
choices right here yeah in the menu so
you can see the hype meter feedback
right right so whenever you're paying
into an audience you're hitting the
right beats hype goes up because you're
in the wrong beach you're not reading
the room the hype goes down that hype
impacts the height meter in the next
battle which needs to be a buffer
so one of the things that the hype meter
does is it captures the feeling of live
wrestling so that the audience energy's
part of the match is part of what's
happening so if you would use the same
moves over and over and over
the audience isn't like that you'll see
the hype meter drop and that changes
your character decisions now that's
pretty cool yeah i really like that
aspect because again it it breaks that
monotonous gameplay loop and you have to
try to do different things to maintain
that crowd without energy and this is
very much an active rpg you can see
things like
the pin mechanics and the unique
character agency required to build out
different move sets and you know making
your choices on what your tag teams and
triple tag teams look like nice nice
this is really cool the purpose is
absolutely awesome we get dive we lost
some height right there we're going to
continue on now from a gameplay
perspective we're talking rpgs what are
we looking like long term for as far as
like hours gameplay
we've worked on this like three and a
half years man living in wrestle quest i
absolutely love it requesting the it's
basically
a marriage of two worlds yeah man
actually i'm glad you said that it's
actually three worlds break it down so
it's wrestling rpgs and toys oh i love
it so so much that imaginative wrestling
gameplay is folks maybe only had a
matchman action figure and they might be
fighting a gi joe or ximena right so
that's actually what's captured him i
love it man this is really cool now far
from a development standpoint how long
has it been in development three and a
half years okay and now wow three and a
half now what about engine wise what are
we using to say unity
yeah
it's pretty cool man you feel unity no
i'm not a devil myself but i know a lot
of you no doubt utilize it and you see
it it looks i i just love the art style
and the ease of use it looks like for
development what's up i've noticed it
kind of like i'm not
like a wrestling person but i know like
you're getting like uh like history
lessons on
yes so each legendary wrestler has an
autobiographical story foundation right
so so people who have no wrestling
knowledge can be dropped into wrestle
quest and get rammed up
that's cool
[Music]
there's too many secret boxes
he's all about the bosses all about the
boss encounters and that now has piqued
his interest and this is coming from a
non-wrestling
but that is good i actually think
wrestle quest is more of an rpg than a
wrestling game
you know very much rbg speaking of
wrestling games do you know lord
sovereigns here
we go
so we're talking about this game russell
cross we got the legendary
the building legendary jump jack in the
building
so look so we've been talking about this
game we got the amazing developer in the
building it is a marriage pretty much of
rpg wrestling and toys yes so what is
exciting you
about this game
just the fact that
what i'm assuming is like a somewhat
comedic take on
what happens behind the scenes in
wrestling everything that some of that
as long time wrestling fans right you're
in on the gag right
you know wrestling doesn't take itself
too seriously
so it to me a game for a person like me
that's been it
loves wrestling hasn't followed a lot
recently with just that idea of what
happened you just left that macho stuff
throwing the game so you go back up and
out
go back to the um go back here start
your character from yeah
[Music]
and also with the promos cutting
gaining height losing height you got
that whole bit so as long as you're
explaining an attic right there so you
can let our differences know one more
time what were you explaining to lord
addict right there as far as advancing
you know so much of rpgs are about
exploring where you're going and looking
for crannies
kind of give them like the guided
wrestling shirt for speed run for pax
so we're just getting back on track with
you know face paints and handshakes
quest okay so this kind of introduced
you to more game mechanics you're
putting a wrestle raider here okay okay
let's go
start this off
all right
okay so we're just getting them
acclimated yeah reinforcing the tutorial
kind of get the get the vibe kicked out
you have a chance to apply the hype
meter skill now yeah what's interesting
is
this is awesome yeah no doubt no doubt
so yeah this is really cool man i'm
absolutely loving it so again uni now as
far as on platforms and close to release
so so pc console nintendo switch ps5 ps4
xbox xbox one
we're looking at uh we look at that
sometime fall okay okay
now as far as like i said the
personalities and i think
is there a possibility for the future
for more
additives i think man we're so stacked
up on future wrestle quest content
okay
so the world map is tough no doubt man
okay okay okay that's what i like to
hear look man
i
like
wrestlers that you know in the game yeah
so we have about 30 licensed wrestlers
like macho road warriors
and do they give you like they give you
press throughout the well i can't i
can't spoil it for you man
yeah yeah of course
he's like i can't give you anything
he's like where did that game play got
these guys in there yeah oh my lord this
is this is awesome man coco be wearing
is there any like tag team stuff you
don't get enough coco dude yeah never
never wants to know more about any the
tag team aspect
yeah so later in the game
you would expect any of these uh kind of
dual team maneuvers to unfold in
wrestling there's there's two man moves
just like you'd see in wrestling things
like the doomsday device legion dreams
to do right yep so we have uh some
unique character references for that
based on our characters we build out and
then based on some of the new gimmicks
you move and choose awesome man we are
super excited again the wrestling quest
in the building one of the more highly
anticipated games coming out from pretty
much all major platforms on my pc no
doubt coming soon ton of content we got
the legends in the building we got jeff
jared about song this is our heart this
is like
playing these games we're playing
putting quarters in wrestling fast
playing pro wrestling like this is that
error that we like wrestling for the
sake of this bro
for the math system
with the big hair wrestling would do
yeah i gotta come to the panel friday
man that's what it's all about oh okay
we gotta check you out we're doing a
history of wrestling and gaming panel
once yeah nice now for people who want
to know more about the game where can
they go twitter accounts
wrestlingquest.com that's request.com
you heard it here first the legendary in
the building wrestle quest excitement
even attica now wrestling fans into it
go check it out go support the game you
got your character in the building i
love podcasts more common you know here
lord sovereign lord attic again an
absolute pleasure man thank you thank
you guys for shopping yeah
[Music]
you